let's go next to our caller from the
three one five area code who is calling
today from three one five uh hey David
what would you like your parents to grow
up under the military government you
know well
they I mean so let's so my very good
question my parents did grow up I was
born in Argentina shortly after the end
of the military regime in Argentina my
parents in the 70s you know were young
adults older teenagers and young adults
in the 70s and they were leftists so you
know imagine that you have a coffee shop
and this is a real example from my dad
you have a cafe where the sort of lefty
philosophy Poli Sci students are known
to hang out that becomes a place that is
unsafe because you've got informants of
the military dictatorship
you've got oppression being done by the
military so hey that the cafe is no
longer a safe place for you to go and
just chat with people my parents have
friends who who were disappeared as the
term is certainly you know killed so
they were you know fortunately they were
okay obviously I mean they survived and
and I was born but they were in the
thick of it they lost friends I think
we've had we have extended family that
was killed and they were right in it I
mean they lived through a military
dictatorship the likes of which is is
inconceivable to most American youth
hello oh boy all right well listen I I
answered not not clear what happened
there but appreciate the phone call